[Musique]
bonsoir mercredi 1er avril bienvenue
dans cette édition spéciale sur tv 78
dédié à la pandémie de coronavirus
la crise sanitaire du coc vide 19 qui
est toujours en phase ascendante dans la
région et le département aux derniers
chiffres publiés hier 98 personnes ont
succombé au virus dans les hôpitaux
yvelinois ont recensé hier 706
hospitalisation sur le territoire plus
112 en 24 heures 158 personnes étaient
placées en réanimation mardi soir a
contrario le nombre de retour à domicile
suite à une amélioration de l'état de
santé est lui aussi en progression et
les hôpitaux qui arrive à saturation
avec un nombre de malades en réanimation
plus conséquent que le nombre de places
disponibles en ile de france
l'urgence est donc de trouver de
nouveaux lits d'ouvrir de nouveaux lits
et aussi à la production de respirateurs
artificiels pour les équiper l usine psa
de poissy se joint à l'effort du moment
l'entreprise a répondu à l'appel
d'offres d'air liquide
objectif produire et 10000 respirateur
d'ici mai 60 salariés des 3500 du site
dont donc assemblés sur place est des
composants mécaniques qui seront ensuite
envoyés à l'usiné
air liquide antony dans les
hauts-de-seine écoutez les explications
du directeur industriel de psa
face à cette situation exceptionnelle
notre entreprise s'est mobilisée d'une
part un groupe de travail d'une
trentaine d'experts à étudier la
meilleure façon de produire les
respirateurs plus rapidement et en
grande quantité en parallèle dans la
mesure où dans notre usine de poissy
nous avons mis en place les mesures de
sécurité sanitaire renforcée pour
protéger nos salariés nous avons décidé
d'y installer un atelier pour produire
le bloc central des respirateurs
artificiels et puis enfin des salariés
volontaires du groupe
vous aussi rejoindre les ateliers d'air
liquide pour prêter main forte à
l'assemblage des respirateurs les
salariés impliqués sont tous volontaires
et leur dossier médical leur permet un
retour à l'usiné ils sont d'ores et déjà
engagés comme le précise le délégué psa
poissy de force ouvrière qui restera
tout de même vigilant sur la sécurité
des salariés
aujourd'hui on a un certain nombre de
nos collaborateurs la ligne managériale
des salariés des moniteurs qui sont
partis sur le site d'antony pour
apprendre un peu les gestuelles et
apprendre
les techniques de montage on a aussi des
techniciens qui sont en train de
regarder le processus de fabrication
pour pouvoir adapter les postes de
travail sur notre site
en parallèle nous n'a fait à c est ce
vendredi pour expliquer quels sont les
les musées les mesures de deux gestes
barrières qu'on va mettre en place pour
éviter que la propagation parce que être
solidaire c'est une chose mais c'est la
solidarité veut dire qu'on remplit aussi
les hôpitaux c'est pas vraiment être
solidaire donc les principes de
barrières qui est qu'ils vont être mis
en place
ce seront des délégués de destination
des équipes ou qui sont fournis par la
direction pour pouvoir contribuer à
cette fabrication à la et puis pour être
complet sur le sujet il se félicite de
voir l'usiné psa a participé à la
production des respirateurs artificiels
le maire de poissy à karl olive salut
dans un communiqué la démarche du groupe
implantée dans la ville
cette guerre ne se gagnera qu'en faisant
front tous ensemble en faisant nation a
affirmé l'élu yvelinois et des
respirateurs artificiels je vous le
disais nécessaires pour équiper les lits
des hôpitaux
seuls les cas graves nécessitent une
hospitalisation pour les autres
personnes présentant des symptômes du
coït 19 la médecine générale
s'organisent elles nous vous parlions la
semaine dernière de l'ouverture de
centres de consultation dédiés dans les
yvelines et 18 sont aujourd'hui ouverts
et en place sur le territoire comme à
poitiers
sur ces images est dernier en date
ouverts dans le département un centre du
côté de montigny le bretonneux
ces centres permettent de recevoir à
proximité des hôpitaux des patients qui
ont été arrêtés par leur médecin
généraliste ou le samu écoutez ses
explications au micro de patrick jacques
de dixmude
il existe donc là ici dans les yvelines
actuellement 18 centres qui permettent
d'accueillir en deuxième recours les
patients c'est à dire que le patient qui
est suspect va contacter le case ou son
médecin
et si le kazoo les médecins considèrent
qu'il ya un risque majeur d'infection et
que donc ce patient pourrait être
infectés et transmettre l'infection il
va être adressée vert à des centres
qu'ovide condom que les drom qui
permettent de pouvoir les accueillir
dans des bonnes conditions donc grâce à
cela nous préservons les patients et
puis nous nous protégeons l'activité
hospitalière de telle manière qu'elle
puisse continuer à s'exercer vers les
cas graves et les cas évoluer situation
également compliqué dans les ehpad très
touché par la pandémie avec une
population à risque pour assister les
soignants dans ce contexte de crise
sanitaire
une entreprise d'elancourt poursuit son
activité blue line et à est engagé dans
le secteur de la dépendance et propose
de la téléassistance des personnes âgées
au travers de système d'appel d'urgence
et nicolas landry pour l'interview
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une réalité que nous
vivons depuis maintenant 15 jours
e
à la fois parce que nous accompagnons
des personnes âgées qui sont à leur
domicile sont près de 30000 en france et
puis nous accompagnons aussi des ehpad
donc des résidences services des
résidences seniors où nos solutions sont
présentées vous là aussi on accompagne à
la fois on assiste les soignants est à
la fois on gère la relation avec les
familles donc vous savez tous
aujourd'hui dans la situation dans
laquelle nous vivons tous
c'est une population qui est très
fragilisée et qui est surtout en
souffrance on a mis en place toute une
série de process dents au sein de notre
entreprise une partie des collaborateurs
travaillent en télétravail et on a
laissé cette plateforme fonctionner
depuis saint quentin en yvelines pour
être certain que nous ayons la bonne
réactivité et les bons retours donc nous
sommes très aujourd'hui très sollicité
les personnes âgées que nous
accompagnons ont des boutons d'appel
chez eux au détecteur de chute et ils
peuvent les manipuler à tout moment
souvent lorsqu'ils se sentent surtout
seul et puis il ya aussi de plus en plus
de d'actions qui sont on doit appeler ou
les voisins ou les services de secours
et sur ses services de secours ils sont
très mobilisés aujourd'hui sur le co
vide 19
donc il faut qu'on soit le plus efficace
possible auprès de leurs services pour
avoir les bons mots les bonnes
terminologie et puis qu'on puisse ainsi
apporter le maximum de soutien aux
familles
en attendant et en ayant quelques
échanges avec des directeurs
d'établissements aujourd'hui leur
quotidien c'est quoi des centres
d'hébergement de qui accueille des
personnes en situation de handicap ou
des centres de type l'ehpad résidence
seniors résidence autonomie qui
accueillent des personnes âgées
ils sont totalement noyée par leur
quotidien il faut qu'ils gèrent leur
équipe
il faut qu'ils gèrent les familles fonds
qu'ils gèrent leur résidence et on a eu
une idée comme on a une plateforme avec
aujourd'hui des écoutes en décharge et
d'écouté d'assistance on s'est dit qu'on
pourrait aussi assister ces personnes
ces soignants en étant là présent et 11
ans quelque part la coordination on a
aussi eu une idée c'est de pourquoi pas
à contacter les restaurateurs qui son
retour de certains ehpad et de leur dire
si vous avez des invendus ou si vous
avez quelques repas chauds qui sont
encore disponibles bah écoute et à les
livrer à l'ehpad d'à côté il ya une
équipe qui travaille toute la nuit qui
sera très contente et qui va adorer
recevoir ça ça serait proche de
reconnaissance 16e jour de confinement
en france avec vous le savez des
déplacements réduit au strict
essentielles sur l'attestation de
déplacement dérogatoire figurent
notamment l'assistance aux personnes
vulnérables
il est par exemple tout à fait possible
de continuer à donner son sang et ses
plaquettes elle nouveauté depuis ce
lundi les donneurs franciliens doivent
prendre rendez vous avant de se déplacer
l établissement français du sang appelle
à la mobilisation pour garantir la
continuité des stocks
un geste qui reste essentiel et surtout
en cette période exceptionnelle les
propos sont recueillis par mélanie
poquet et nicolas kirillovitch je
rappelle que nous sommes un
établissement de santé
et quand l'état donc nous
nous continuons à collecter que les
malades eux sont toujours malades et que
certes le qu'ovide tourner partons
maintenant mais les malades eux s'ils
n'ont pas leurs produits sanguins il
risque vraiment d'être très très mal une
dizaine de points de collecte sont
ouverts en ile de france il faut donc
prendre rendez vous avant de se déplacer
toutes les informations sur les lieux et
sur la prise de rendez-vous et via le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
il fait partie de ce groupe restreint de
français à avoir été dans l'espace
l'astronaute jean françois clervoy
réside dans le département des yvelines
il a travaillé pendant plusieurs années
sur le site de l'industrie spatiale des
mureaux aujourd'hui comme tout le monde
il est confiné à son domicile écouter
ces quelques conseils pour vivre son
confinement à lui qui a connu
différentes expériences seul loin de la
terre bonjour jean françois clervoy
bonjour vous êtes ingénieur et
astronaute rattaché à l'agencé spatiale
européenne vous avez passé 675 heures
dans l'espace à bord de la navette
d'abord atlantis puis discovery pour
trois missions 1 entre 1994 et 1999
vous êtes actuellement confinés dans
votre domicile dans les yvelines
oui c'est exact où et avec ma femme
parce que mon fils est tout seul dans
son appart dans paris est ma fille et en
australie le confinement finalement ça
doit pas être difficile pour vous c'est
quelque chose que vous avez déjà vécu
dans l'espace alors je vécu le
confinement dans l'espace mais c'est pas
le même il est pas tout à fait
comparable
ici on n'est pas isolés on peut appeler
nos proches on peut avoir de l'aide à
domicile si besoin est on peut sortir
nous dans l'espace on est confiné
parce que dehors le milieu est extrême
et invivable donc nous sommes dans un
confinement étanche est tout petit alors
ça varie avec la durée et le nombre
d'équipages c'est à dire que dans ceux
où vous la capsule russe ces trois
personnes pendant deux jours maximum
dans l'équivalent d'1 5 mètre carré dans
la navette spatiale dans le cockpit
c'est l'équivalent d'un 10 à 12 mètres
carrés pour six à sept personnes pendant
quatre jours mais d'arrestations se
passe et internationales c'est
l'équivalent d'un 300 m² pour six
personnes pendant six mois d'envoyer le
confinement dépend beaucoup les
collections confinement du volume du
nombre de personnes et bien sûr de la
durée donc le confinement je les connais
aussi un peu similaire a su qu'on lui
maintenant avant le vol tous les
astronautes sont en quarantaine pendant
une quinzaine de jours pour éviter
d'attraper une maladie au dernier moment
parfois ils sont en quarantaine après ça
arrivait rarement mais c'est arrivé pour
éviter de contaminer le public à
l'extérieur avec d éventuels microbes
ramené du milieu extra terreste c'est le
cas des missions apollo par exemple
dans quel état d'esprit on se trouve
dans un confinement dans l'espace mais
aussi sur terre pour la préparation de
ses voyages
alors effectivement c'est une bonne
question de la différence fondamentale
entre le confinement nous vivons tous en
ce moment est le nôtre dans l'espace
c'est que celui que nous avons dans
l'espace on y est préparé
on n'y pense même pas on sait qu'on a
besoin d'être protégé et notre
confinement pour nous c'est un abri
c'était une fonction protectrice et on
est obligé de l'accepter pour la mission
qu'on a accepté et on y est préparé
là il ya une grande majorité des gens
qui sont pas du tout préparés ils n'ont
jamais vécu le confinement à part celui
qui est randonneurs qui fait du camping
dans des milieux un peu extrême
il sait ce que c'est quand on est
confiné donc la règle de base
quand je vois qu'on file dans l'espace
ou chez soi il faut savoir pourquoi
pourquoi je suis confiné
quand il ya un sens quand il ya un but
quand il ya une mission derrière on
l'acceptent parce que on veut remplir la
mission
après il faut être organisé organisée
dans l'espace parce que on peut parfois
pas facilement à sortir de chez soi vous
savoir quelles sont les ressources à
bord par exemple ne serait-ce que de
nourriture de pièces de rechange ou de
doughty s'il ya besoin de réparer les
choses et et après partager avec les
autres des ressources par exemple la
salle de bain par exemple à l'écran de
télé entre les enfants qui veulent voir
des dessins animés ou les ados qui
veulent le voir je jouais avec des jeux
vidéo donc être organisées dans l'espace
ranger parce que très rapidement cette
diane bazar si on est pardonné et puis
avoir un planning
nous on a un plan de vol voilà je vous
montre ici le plan de vol de mon
troisième vol spatial qui était un vol
destiné à réparer le télescope spatial
hubble
c'était un gros bouquin check list qui
décrit presque à la minute près qui fait
quoi quand et où
donc nous avons un but à atteindre nous
avons un confinement qui nous protège du
milieu extérieur et nous avons un plan
d'activité
c'est très important d'être de
s'astreindre apte à se donner un
planning
si on attend que quelqu'un nous dise
quoi faire on peut facilement se
retrouver à devenir oisifs et c'est
malsain et bien sûr le sport le sport
est prévue chaque jour merci jean
françois clervoy pour ce témoignage et
ses conseils
bien je vous souhaite à tous de bien
vivre à travers ce confinement en
pensant toujours à la mission pour qu'on
sorte tous indemme en très bonne santé
pas de visite au cinéma aujourd'hui
comme nous en avions l'habitude chaque
mercredi sur tv 60,18 ces salles de
cinéma sont aujourd'hui bien sûr fermé
et mais rassurez vous à la place nous
vous proposons une sélection de films à
voir et directement depuis votre canapé
la sélection du jour est faite par le
versailles et vincent mirabel professeur
de cinéma et auteur de l'histoire du
cinéma pour les nuls regarder quels sont
vos coups de coeur qu'elle filme peut-on
regarder pendant cette période de
confinement c'est edward aux mains
d'argent
un film de tim burton qui sort 15 mai 1
191 peut-être l'avez-vous vu vous même
ou effectivement bon vous avez aimé je
suppose
oui c'est très magique comme film oui
c'est magique alors c'est un conte de
fées en fait effectivement avec un
personnage à la fois inquiétant et
attachant alors edouard vous souvenez
c'est une créature humaine qui a été
mise au point par un inventeur qui lui a
donné un coeur qui lui a donné un
cerveau intelligent mais qui n'a pas eu
le temps de finir tout à fait son
physique et notamment ses mains qui se
terminent actuellement par des des lames
coupante et pointue et l'inventeur va
mourir et laisse cette créature
et rés alors tout le récit c'est
évidemment de sortir d'un isolement dans
une propriété un peu magique et
inquiétante assez gothique et il va
devoir en fait affronter le monde et
peut-être trouvé la mort alors les
atouts de ce film qui est célèbre parce
que il ya eu 91 % de taux de
satisfaction dans toutes les critiques
ce qui est absolument énorme et même le
public a vraiment plébiscité ce film
alors d'abord il est à croiser des gens
c'est à la fois un conte c'est
fantastique
mais c'est un peu comme eddy aussi et
puis c'est finalement un drame
romantique alors le film a comme atout
aussi de démarrer un trio gagnant
c'est tim burton d'abord le réalisateur
qui va en fait faire alliance avec son
acteur qui va devenir son acteur fétiche
johnny depp
alors on le retrouvera plus tard dans ed
wood dans ce qui est pire l'eau ou dans
sweeney todd
johnny depp était à l'époque un acteur
peu connu il avait surtout été un
policier dans la série 21 jump
frites et là il va éclore il va trouver
son réalisateur et le récepteur va
également trouver non seulement cet
acteur majeur mais également un
compositeur absolument géniale qui est
danny elfman et qui va composer une
musique extraordinaire
en tout cas dany elfman considère que
cette oeuvre
edward aux mains d'argent et sa musique
la plus personnelle tout comme
d'ailleurs le réalisateur qui trouvent
que ce film est tout à fait à son image
petite dernière anecdote on voit
vinh-san price qui est un acteur qui a
beaucoup joué
le compte de dracula mais également
frankenstein qui fait sa dernière
apparition dans ce film c'est lui
l'inventeur de la créature et pour
retrouver ce film en vidéo à la demande
de rendez vous sur le site du centre
national du cinéma le cnc propose un
moteur de référencement qui vous permet
de trouver très facilement le film que
vous recherchez
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de votre fidélité on se
quitte sur ces images est la résidence
la vigne ray aux clayes-sous-bois au
rendez vous chaque soir à 20h pour
applaudir le personnel soignant l'élan
s'observe partout en france et dans le
département
restez chez vous et très belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
allez
[Musique]